round eight of the Sinquefield cup the  most exciting tournament of the year  here in st. Louis with three players  tied the first attention was at a fever  pitch as submitting a single mistake  could cost the entire tournament  vishwanath on a nine and Eckstein  vassella grab plates withdraw and when  911 Aronian or Magnus cross was able to  win their games the leaders were unable  to create any separation from the rest  of the pack that left a door open for  Sergey kuryakin's who defeated Jewish  champion Wesley so to bring the Russians  large as a half the points out of the  lead  with also play form of the last day if  more time any one of five players to win  the title final round of action for all  the marbles starts right now